everybody has their pinnacle like if you
look at your own personal history of
gaming expertise everybody has that
moment where it's like this is where I
peaked and was like I could have been a
pro and for me it was half-life one
deathmatch which any competitive FPS
players like rolling their eyes right
now like really do like you could have
said quake 3 or counter-strike or
something like but I swear to god I was
I was god like in half-life 1 deathmatch
I could literally kill entire Maps with
the crowbar alone I'm throwing snarks at
everyone exactly
the word MOBA is a filthy word in the
world of video games
it's like mustard you're either in or
you're out and it was a word that was
thrown around quite a lot when overwatch
first hit the gaming consciousness back
in 2014 and with so many mobile like
shooters hitting the news at the same
time it was no wonder but the truth is
overwatch isn't a MOBA in fact you get
right down and play it it's a game that
almost feels like a best dog collection
of some of the shooters many of us grew
up playing in fact when talking to the
team about how the game was crafted it's
amazing just how many games were used as
inspiration but personally my first
question when I first heard about
overwatch was what the hell are blessed
doing making an online shooter what does
a studio known for making games about
wizards and goblins and flying lion
birds know about online shooters well as
it turns out quite a lot there was a mod
for quake 2 called action quake and some
of the guys who worked on action quake
went on to work on counter-strike there
was a split it was action half-life and
counter-strike were what was going to
become of the action quake community and
action quake was one of the greatest
mods of all time so I was following
those guys from the get-go and I was
around in counter-strike back in the day
when you could cycle weapons back to
your spawn so if your team was winning
you would kill most of the enemy team
and let's say there was one terrorists
left you didn't kill him you took all
the weapons on the map and you just
cycled them all the way back to your
spawn then you ran you killed the guy
and now all the good weapons were
waiting at your spawn so I was around in
pretty early days of those things
half-life 1 shipped with the math editor
on the disk and ironically the name of
the map editor was world craft just to
add confusion to it all but it was
amazing program and there was a really
thriving modding community and mapping
community going on
and that's where I was really learning
it previously made maps for games like
Duke Nukem which had also shipped with
the map editor on the disc but it was
really in half-life that I really had a
feel for what it takes to make a map and
have it run well and have other people
play tested and it was super excited
made a couple maps for that before Jeff
Goodman who's Arizona working on
overwatch he and actually and I were
actually in a Team Fortress clan we
didn't even like no we didn't even know
each other like I was working in
Blizzard and he was wasn't sure where he
was and he got at export Java Blizzard
as Ari came up through the ranks and we
like we both here and sort of this weird
like well that's just a bit of like
weird like synergistic stuff it's like
how did all this happen
but yeah but now we're making this like
really awesome shooter and we can't be
happier what was it like jumping into
the first persons basically I don't know
it's some level I want to say you know
terrifying no safety net like what could
you guys possibly be thinking when
there's so many shots in the industry
that do this just that our world-class
experts at this content but I believe
you know Jeff Kaplan had an instinct of
the product they wanted to make and how
it would feel I mean I think a lot of us
were FPS fans for our whole lives and so
there's always been this kind of dream
to work on an FPS in the FPS unlike a
lot of other genres the FPS is very
explored there have been there's such a
diversity in what people do with FPSOs
there's also a mastery in the genre
there are a lot of you know there's some
genres that you look at and you see as
fertile ground where it's there are cool
ideas but nobody's ever done the great
game in the genre
whereas with FPS there are many great
games or many all-time you know you want
to put them on the wall hall of fame
type of games you know I have behind my
desk over there I actually had the boxes
for Doom 1 and doom 2 like just sitting
there and in honor of like sort of the
greatness so it's a daunting genre to
step into the fans know exact
what they want out of the genre and are
very particular so it's you're kind of
stepping into something that is hallowed
ground and you have to be very careful
to respect what has been done there for
20 years before you presumably though
you guys thought that there was
something that people hadn't nailed yet
but there was there was something that
you guys could do to nobody had done
before absolutely I think it was a mix
of things I think one FPS is in the past
you know once a decade have been
trending towards realism and modern
military or if if they stepped outside
of realism it was towards gritty near
future and sort of barely near future
you know like here's what an ak-47 would
look like five years from now so we felt
like there was a space to explore that
went beyond that the other thing that we
didn't see a lot of happening was new
and unique movement so having come from
sort of the quake modding community
where I remember when segwaying from
quake one to quake 2 there's like a
missus race in the modding community who
can make the grapple hook the fastest
but it was all about rocket jumping and
grapple hooks and there's even grenade
jumping and it was you know how could
you move around the map quickly and in
these really like flew in elegant ways
and one of the things that we wanted to
sort of bring back to the FPS was
abilities and movement and fluidity and
how you moved and scale like you know
Widowmaker who's our sniper for example
a lot of people use her grapple not just
to get up to a high vantage point but to
actually launch themselves and snipe
wall in air so we wanted to get into
some of that really high skill ethic
sort of fluid really fun to watch type
of gameplay added to that was team
gameplay so I think the Masters of Team
gameplay in the FPS genre was the team
fortress series and it started with Team
Fortress the mod for quake 1 which was
amazing one of my favorites ever then I
don't hear a lot of people talk about it
but Team Fortress classic which was the
update to half-life 1 and again as a
half-life 1 guy just lost lost myself in
that for so long and then Team Fortress
2 in a lot of ways especially when it
launched back in 2007 was as perfect of
a design of a team-based shooter as you
could ever achieve I mean visually from
the gameplay mechanics from the balance
from the maps and the modes it was just
a brilliant brilliant game and what had
happened over the years since Team
Fortress 2's release is we had this big
boom of MOBA games and I think the thing
that really spoke to people in MOBAs
more than anything was how coordinated
teams could really be successful and the
Team Fortress competitive community knew
that this existed but that community was
really small at the Team Fortress
community was huge in terms of who was
playing it but a lot of us were playing
it in pubs where we get on these servers
that we modified you know like I'm
playing 12 v12 instant respawn and it
was just kind of this chaos meat grinder
where I think the tf2 competitive people
realize like no if you really coordinate
and play this in a tight competitive way
it's all about the team play that you
saw exploding in MOBAs and those games
were built from the get-go to embrace
you know in their case 5 v 5 gameplay so
I think we saw a refinement that could
take place that said well what if you
had these cool abilities epic you know
abilities happening great movement and
then really embrace the team play an
objective based gameplay but really
focused people on winning or losing as a
group so I think all those elements
combined are what
to overwatch becoming overwatch you
think of all the ideas from all the
first-person shooters
during that amount of time there's a lot
of like like great ideas to you know to
explore and like said okay that worked
back then like what can we do with it
now and make even better we knew I mean
the rocket launcher is probably the we
think first-person shooter just like
assault rifles and rocket launchers like
between those two we knew we were going
to have someone with a rocket launcher
and very early on it was sort of
interesting that we were first doing our
one of our first milestones initially we
didn't really only plan for like three
heroes it was like we were tracer and
like what I make her and Jeff Goodman
was like I think I can get a rocket
launcher character and like super fast
and he just did it and it was sort of
course we're gonna put a rocket launch
it was like yes we're doing that and
it's like if we get that in like super
fast do it yeah so we sort of snuck you
know fair end of that like mouse ton
even when she wasn't called fair I think
you know her code name was rocket queen
like if you go and like blood like a
felony and it's not fair a dot you know
whatever it's like rocket queen we knew
were eventually going to do someone with
a grenade launcher like chunk rockin
like later on during doing on but like
we are we'd always talked about it was
like that was over because was one of
the things when we were developing tore
burn was Oh turrets are like super
strong it's like we have but we're gonna
do them we're gonna do the grenade
launcher character and that's going to
change things because he can lob the
grenades and like you know hit the
turrets where the turrets can't fire
back and then we just like okay then we
finally did it and that we did it with
like our spin with the traps and the
remote control controlled detonation
there's a lot to talk about when it
comes to hero design especially how many
of them reference classic shooters of
old and some not-so-old but we'll dive
into that properly in the third video in
this series right now I want to de quiz
Jeff I bet the many ways in which
overwatch is entirely similar to many
online shooters I want to ask him about
its game modes its map design and have
exactly you breathe new life into such
well-trodden ground the game owns
themselves are sort of familiar most
them are we've seen them in other games
is that like almost intentional because
if you start make some of game modes and
and all those different heroes it sort
of might over complicate it for a friend
for players absolutely and in fact you
guys are here visiting us in our space
you walk around you'll see we'll have
things up on the wall and on one of the
walls out there is sort of our level
design high level guiding goals and one
of the first ones is it's all about the
heroes which is a funny thing to say
about the level design like the maps and
the level design is it's all about the
heroes every game mode that we ever do
we want to make sure that we don't shift
the focus of the players there's a lot
going on when you're playing overwatch
it's a very fast paced game things are
coming at you very quickly and you need
an immediate read on what's going on the
battlefield also there are roles and
sort of strengths and weaknesses to all
the characters if we try to over
engineer a game-mode too much you're
going to suddenly lose focus on what the
chord the game is and the core the game
should be you know hey Steven over there
is playing Pharaoh right now maybe I
should switch to 76 or McCree because I
think I'm really good at countering
Farah the 76 ARMA 3 some of the game
modes that we explore get very
complicated and gimmicky and you get in
these modes of like you know okay
there's two fools and then there's
widgets and then you need to get the
widgets to the few Souls and if Foose
Olay gets to has more widgets than foods
will be
and basically and suddenly you're
thinking of the interface you need to do
that and then you're lost in it all is
well what happened to tracer and what
happened to Winston and what happened to
Widowmaker they don't matter anymore so
it's a very deliberate choice for us to
pick game modes that in a lot of ways
fade into the background
it's the game is not about you know
wacky crazy game modes the game is at
its essence about these amazing heroes
and things that you're able to
accomplish with them there are some
things that are really worried about at
the start of the process going from
designing space and World of Warcraft or
any open-world game because I ended up
transitioning over to the exterior level
design team there and the spaces there
are huge you're building whole zones and
you're really worried about vistas and
and kind of how it how it feels just
unlike an immersion level a lot of the
time and so I was really worried about
scale when we first started because it'd
be so easy to just kind of keep running
with what we had on Wow and so we did a
lot of research early on into how big a
map ought to be and how big even just
one engagement area ought to be we did a
lot of work looking at other games we
loaded up a lot of Team Fortress 2 and
Call of Duty even in their editors and
we kind of started measuring things out
to just see what it was that those games
did and it was actually really
interesting to me that in my head I was
expecting those games spaces to be a lot
different
then than they were but they're actually
pretty similar a lot of the engagement
distances and those we did a lot of work
on on scale and how far away we wanted
people shooting each other we were
looking a lot at fov and character speed
because they all kind of go hand in hand
and once we started feeling that that
worked well it everything became about
the heroes in the game team deathmatch
is a really interesting one that comes
up first of all team deathmatch in a lot
of ways becomes an oxymoron to me and
that's not a fair statement but team
deathmatch just means I don't get to
kill half the people but I'm not really
coordinating or interacting with the
other members of my team it's in all the
games that I played with team deathmatch
you have these moments where you run
around a corner
and you kind of look at the other guy
okay.i and then you run like carry on
like please don't take my kill like
that's sort of all or you're annoyed
that the other guy died I'm also in a
hero based game like overwatch if you
look at a hero like mercy like what does
she become if we if we sort of just
reduced the game down to the team
deathmatch she's I think in a lot of
ways you break a character like that or
you break a character like Symetra who
in a team-based objective game there's
some of the most powerful characters we
have but in a pure deathmatch they
suddenly become really questionable
choices we do not design our characters
to be this perfectly balanced 1v1
rock-paper-scissors like every hero can
beat every other hero what in a 1v1
situation there absolutely not balance
in tune that way so it would sort of be
a disservice to a lot of our heroes to
sort of make the folks of the game more
of a team deathmatch
to that point as well you've also done
you know something that almost like
never occurred to our team-based games
is like stripping it that sort of kill
death ratio hunts that everyone has in
not having traditional score screens
used to sort of speak to the FOS behind
that decision yeah absolutely it's it's
something I'm really happy to talk about
because there's been a miscommunication
exception our community that you know
Blizzard doesn't have a traditional
scoreboard because they're catering to
the casuals and they're a bunch of Care
Bears and it's all about toxicity and I
find those conversations really
interesting and I think that there's you
know some valid arguments people have
made in terms of toxicity but that
hasn't been the reason at all and in
fact if you go back and look at older
versions of the game we used to have a
scoring system and we iterated endlessly
on these score boards and scoring
systems and what's the perfect score but
that the score board that a lot of
players want is what I call the
spreadsheet it's just rows and columns
of everything and then like let us
figure it out but it feels like kind of
a give up moment to us because we want
players to be able to look at look at
the scoreboard and go I know who's
performing really well and I know who's
not and if we just make it about kills
and deaths it doesn't tell the complete
story of who's doing well and who's
doing not like for example you know how
does mercy factor in to a kill death
ratio type of scoring system conversely
you know we have tried other scoring
systems where people were said we'll
make it all about the objective so like
who's on the payload and who's capturing
points and who's not capturing points or
who's killing people on the payload and
not killing people on the payload but we
have characters like tracer and Genji in
the game who are really unique and how
overwatch is played and sometimes the
absolute right thing for tracer to be
doing is to be off on her own completely
away from the objective or completely
away from the team harassing other
players who are running back from the
spawn and she might not even be killing
those but sometimes she's killing them
sometimes she's not she's she's a
distracting ambushing skirmisher and
that doesn't really fit in necessarily
with objective time sometimes it's about
kills with tracer but sometimes it's not
something you can be the absolute MVP of
the match when you're doing some of
those things and there's no way to
really score it accurately so we we
basically stopped displaying any four
of scores kills deaths because it really
wasn't telling the story of who was
doing their job properly to win or lose
as a team and really what it's all about
is did you win or lose as a team
and none of that other stuff really
matters at the end of the day and we
always want your team of six to be
working together to accomplish an
objective together and whether that's a
stated objective in the game such as
escort this payload or capture this
control point or it's some of our softer
objectives which is just break through
this choke point we quickly started
developing a series of things that we'd
use in the map to bring a whole team
together whether it was on offense or
defense to kind of break through and
accomplish what they needed to
from listening to the designers talk
about overwatch one thing comes across
this is a group of individuals who are
incredibly well versed in game design
this coupled with a deep respect for the
FPS lineage and a passion for classic
shooters means they are well equipped to
try and deliver something new in what
has become a rather stale genre of late
as you've seen from today's video they
very much have their sights set on team
play as the way to achieve this but
we've only told half of that story
tomorrow when our third and final video
we explore the heroes of overwatch how
they connect this game with plastic
shooters of old and how a team hopes to
balance a game with 21 different
characters on offer see you then
actually last question who is the hero
that has caused you the most hassle as a
map designing oh my gosh
it's Farah Ferran Widowmaker they can
just get anywhere in a map and it's
always one of the two of them you see
all the forum's just I got over here I
got over here and so we spend a lot of
time fixing bugs associated with you
either of those guess who went to favor
cog design sarin Widowmaker yeah thanks
a lot
you
you